[Music]
I'm Kelly freed from the Microsoft fix
team this is a camera that puts AI
inside so that you get the best photo as
I move this around we have a DNN that's
trained to find the best exposure so it
works hard where to pick the best
exposure so when I take the picture then
10 frames some from before and some from
after the shutter click the ideas that
takes the time to actually click the
shutter and so by taking some before and
after we make sure you get the right
moment then we have live image as well
so it detected that there was some
motion in the image so we actually
create a we stitch the frames together
to create a small live moment you can
also edit so we have face beautification
features that clean up skin as well as
style transfer stuff allows you to add
styles to your image and we also have a
speed painting which
[Music]
hate and you can share either the image
or the painting version of the image and
you can download this at the Apple
iPhone app store or if you're on Android
it should be coming in beta soon